Why do we need data standards?
This simple illustration
helps to make that clear
using a seemingly obvious
data element: gender.
It also helps explain
the difference between syntax,
which is structure, and
semantics, which is meaning.
Here, in system A, male is represented
by a one, and female by a zero.
Over here in system B, that's reversed,
with zero representing male and
one representing female.
Should you mix data from these
two systems without some
intervening standard, gender would be
impossible to determine accurately for
reporting and other purposes.
We say these two systems
differs syntactically.
They maybe using the same
language of one's and zero's, but
they can't interoperate without some
intermediate translation process that
maps one to the other, or
both to some common syntax.
Over in system C, M is used for
male, and F for female.
We say that system C differs
semantically from systems A and
B, it uses a different
language to represent gender.
Moreover, system C recognizes
that gender may be ambiguous, and
represent that with a U, a concept
the other two systems don't deal with.
Interoperability between system C and
the other two systems would require
translation from its syntax to theirs,
or translations of both syntaxes
to a common form, a standard.
Since patients with gender U can't
be represented in systems A and
B, some accommodation for
that would also have to be made.
If something as seemingly simple and
obvious as gender can lead
to this much complexity,
imagine what happens with concepts such
as a patient's diagnosis, which is
inherently somewhat subjective and
can have thousands of possible values.
That's why we need data standards.